腾飞，
我看了你大学同学的评价，
说你是知心姐姐，
因为我比他们要年长一点。
我在读大学的时候，
在我们班这女生里面年纪最大，
只有一个男生比我年纪要大一点，
是因为我啊，
复读过，
我相当于是考过两次大学，
我第一次考大学是考到了四川的一个西南科技大学，
我在那儿读了一年，
读了一年我觉得这个专业我不合适，
还有我心里面有一点不甘心，
因为我当时是上了重点一本，
但是呢，
嗯，
被重点一本刷下来，
就刷到了四川的这个大学，
后来我就退学了，
退学了回去又读了一年的高三，
又复读，
然后又考到了北京，
然后我每一每一年的高考的分数都是超过重点线的啊，
呃，
第一回考的时候可能考了500多分，
第二回考的时候考了600多分。
所以我读大学的时候，
我比我们班同学年纪都大，
人生就是这样子的，
就是决定你的命运的人生转折，
或者说人生路径，
就那么一两个决定，
就可能会影响你的人生。
当时我退学的时候，
我全家人都不同意，
我爸妈都哭了，
为什么？
因为家里穷嘛，
好不容易考上了大学，
而且我当时在考到四川那个大学的时候，
我还拿到了国家助学金，
拿到了每年5000块钱的国家助学金，
那对于家庭来说就减轻了负担嘛，
就等于是我爸爸妈妈不需要给我支付学费，
只需要给我生活费就可以了，
而且我是我们村儿吧，
我是我们村儿方圆十几二十里地。
难得的一个能考考过重点线的这么一个情况，
那家里酒席都已经摆了，
村里的领导都来喝过酒了，
都来祝贺过了，
那你说你考上了大学，
你再退学，
你退学了之后，
你万一再考不上，
那父母的脸往哪儿搁呢？
万一你在考不上比这个更好的，
那全村都给你送过礼了，
你知道吧，
都都已经给你祝贺过了，
你说你以后不成为笑柄了嘛。
所以我爸妈就不同意，
哭着不同意，
但我还是把所有的行李都寄回到我原来的高中。
当然我是先联系我以前高中的老师，
我说我想复读，
你们能不能不收学费接纳我，
然后我高中老师很高兴，
回来吧，
我们不收你学费，
那也是因为我成绩可能比较好嘛，
对于一个高中来说，
你能考一个重点的名额，
它是一种相当于是也算是一个广告的效应啊，
所以我们当时高中的老师就对我特别好，
说不收我的学费，
然后回来就行，
你自己想办法，
就是有生活费就行，
但是因为我妈已经不同意，
我不同意我不读，
所以爸妈也不给我生活费，
然后我就打电话给我一个初中的同学，
因为他们毕业的早，
他们嗯，
不读书了，
之后就打工嘛，
他可能打工攒了一些钱，
我就打电话给他，
我说你能不能借我钱，
他说需要多少，
我说我一年大概算下来啊，
所有的支出算下来的话，
可能需要个呃，
两三千块钱，
然后他就借给我3000块钱，
我就拿着他借给我的3000块钱回到了我以前的高中啊，
高中的老师对我特别关照，
不光是没有收我的学费，
还会给我去联系各种补课的老师，
联系各种补课的老师也说明白了，
说我挺穷的，
你就象征性的收一下就可以了，
就比如说一个数学老师，
他可能收别人的学费，
收300，
收500，
我去了之后，
我就就象征性的就是给老师交100块钱，
然后我在复读的那一年就是。
心无旁骛吧，
就光背作文，
就是必须要参加那个高考的时候，
我背作文我得背，
背个15天到20天的作文，
然后我高考的时候就正好踩中了那个作文的题材，
我的那个作文是我提前背好的。
这就是为什么说有的时候你觉得农夫这小样也挺没文化的，
有的时候也认错别字儿，
为啥我语文成绩能考132分啊，
好像是就在我们当地是语文的单科状元，
那是因为我下苦功夫，
我就是应付考试，
实际上我的这个文学素养，
或者说我的认知面儿没有那么广，
对于曾经给过我帮助的人，
那我肯定肯定能记住，
就比如说他女儿满周岁的时候，
或者是嗯，
家里面有什么事的时候，
那我肯定得意思得到位，
就这意思啊，
第二次考上的学校是一个提前录取的学校，
第二次参加高考的时候也是超过了重点本科线的几十分吧，
我当时考620多分，
被提前录取了，
提前录取这个学校叫中国青年政治学院。
可能很多人没有听过这个学校，
因为这个学校现在已经被中国社会科学院大学给合并掉了啊，
所以现在就没有这样的中国青年政治学院这个招牌了。
对，
罗翔老师应该是也是这个学校毕业的，
但是我跟罗翔老师不认识啊，
只是发自内心的很尊敬他，
觉得他嗯，
把学习法律变得有趣，
让学习法律这个事情能够进入千家万户，
尤其是能够让年轻的一代对法律有一个认知，
这真真的是功德无量。
我当时考上了，
就是来北京来读大学的时候，
我还记得，
因为我家里面比较穷嘛，
爸妈没有这样的钱啊，
所以是我自己一个人背着行囊。
背着锅碗瓢盆儿。
自己背着通知书，
然后呢？
还有一个，
还有一个是我们当地是一个校友，
她也是跟我考上了同一个大学，
就我俩，
她是一个小男孩儿，
我是一个女生，
她个子不高，
但是呢，
人特别好，
特别敦厚，
一路就是他帮我扛行李，
要后我自己扛着那个行李，
你们就想象一下吧，
锅碗瓢盆大衣服鞋袜的这什么东西都得自己扛，
因为如果我爸妈要送我来一趟的话，
又得花几百块，
那个时候几百块对于我来说就是比如说如果说花600块的话，
对于我来说就是两个月的生活费，
不舍得，
所以我爸妈就是送我来读书的时候，
就是在家门口嘛，
车来了，
我自己就坐着那个车去，
得赶火车，
从家门口出来的时候，
我第一次看到我爸妈送我出门的时候掉眼泪，
就以前有千万次啊，
都不会掉眼泪，
因为以前我也是在市里面读书嘛，
我得从我们家就是坐那种车，
我我跟你说，
我们家坐那个车特别吓人，
看我们那个路到处都是悬崖，
到处都是悬崖，
到处都是那种荆棘，
我告诉你就从那儿敢坐那个车下城里面去念书，
那都是九死一生。
现在好了，
现在国家政策好，
现在国家给修路啊，
把所有的悬崖旁边都一个个石墩子都立起来了，
这样的话，
开那个车就没有那么悬着了，
就以前在那儿坐车的时候，
你坐在窗户边，
你一眼看下去就是万丈深渊，
特别险峻。
而且那个路都是这么这么这么这么这么这么这么来的啊，
盘旋来的，
现在路修好了，
真的国家政策好啊，
都是国家出钱修的路啊，
我是哪里人啊，
贵州铜仁云场停镇李家湾村啊，
欢迎你们去我们贵州去旅游。